I think the the most important foreign
policy question of our time is how to
more equitably distribute the benefits
of globalization and how to guard
against the the the threatening
consequences of globalization the
globalization is as a kind of
increasingly international capitalist
order is a remarkable generator of
wealth just like domestic capitalism has
been a remarkable generator well but
just as the progressives in that
Franklin Roosevelt recognized about
domestic on capitalism that if left
totally unregulated it could produce
such brutal inequalities and
instabilities that in fact it could burn
itself up that capitalism was like a car
that drove very very fast but if you
basically just put a brick on the
accelerator and have no steering wheel
it will go it will go into a wall and
blow itself up and I think that to some
degree that the institutions that were
built to manage the global international
economy built at the end of World War
two the Bretton Woods institutions have
have not kept pace with the very radical
changes in political economy so the
first and as a result the deep
inequities that globalization is
creating I think are a threat to human
freedom and human liberty and the
success of democracy particularly in the
third world I think the other thing that
is to confront the the very dangerous
side effects of globalization one of
which is is global warming for instance
the the way in which our manufacturing
is Purdue and our behavior in a global
as H produces potential environmental
disaster another would be jihadist
terrorism in which the consequences of
improved technology in communication and
transport allow people to evil people to
ride on the wings of globalization to be
able to do dramatic harm to others
unless we have a way of preventing them